お待たせいたしました毎年恒例で犬コンシーラー番手
あるいは両側がブルー健康診断発表のコーナーでございます
ん
はいてみて私肇社長の僕だけじゃなくて周りも含めなんですけども僕の周りと一緒に
働いている人たち全員で愛とし4月にリン軒ドッグに行っております男性
健康が一番大事ですからね何かあってからじゃ遅いということで早期発見が何よりも
大切ということで健康診断じゃなくて私たちにん
原ドッグを行っておりますお届い警察んですけどももう3日前に飯食わなかったに水
飲まなかったりこうなんか尿系させたりこんなか
ねちょっとあまり sabelt 下品になるんですけどももう大なり小なりをよる
かき集め光景でしたわけなんですけども
結果発表していきたいと思いますが普通でまだこの年だと健康診断でいいやみたいな
ことを言われやすいんですけど
大学卒業してから毎年を受けてるんですけどもうなんか早いねってめっちゃ揺れるん
ですよ
根津14歳でもう人間と空気粘土みたいな感じ言われ
んですけど
遅かったら手遅れですよ健康診断では分からない細かい言葉を人間ドックだと分かると
いうことでもうねには音を入れて僕を含め畑のみんなあと僕の後輩とか皆人間ドック
受けさせていただいております皆の蒸発と畑でてると思うんですけれどもここは僕の
情報を皆さんにお伝えしようと思います
いっぱいじゃあ順番に発表していきましょうまず
は進退計測です身長が今回186.3
今まで186ちょっとなかったですけどなぜか伸びて186.3になっておりました
mother 成長中かもしれませんねぇ米炊くの悩み台中でですね
70.1黒になってしまいました
やはり年前は65.6そして去年が68今年が70キロ
年々増えてってやる効果ちょっとお医者さんに指摘されましたねやばいですよ
今は今度ベースなんですけど音ストレートが速くなるんでどこがで食生活を見直したら
いいよっていうことを言われました
野菜食べまして標準体重がですねいずれにせよ僕75キロとは76キロとかなんで7
ちゃっキロでもまだ
痩せてる方なんですよただこのまま行くと70キロになっちゃいそうなんでちょっと
どこがデコストップしたいっていうか抑えたいっていうところでございます水で肥満度
まだマイナス8.2%ですマイナスなのでまだセーフです続いて bmi が8
20.2前回前々回が1979に比べて27買ってしまいましたがまだ大丈夫で体脂肪
率が14%ちょうど
いい具合ですね一順次のいちばん下くらいなのでとてもバランスが良い状態になりまし
たをなざわちょっと歩くれました
キッズ集めまぁ問題無しで白く去年と変わらず0.70.67んですガンガン壷問題
なかったですありがとうございます潮流が問題だしですありがとうございます尿計算
問題ないで去年に続き今年もタンパクが多かったです
なぜでしょと肝機能を特に問題なかったです
43の値も問題だしでここが問題です問題があるとしたらここだったかな
えっ脂質代謝ですねあの中いわゆるでるってやつですコレステロール値が前回が
めっちゃお家で192だったんですけれども
えっと今回が224と五年前と戻ってしまいましたコレステロールもガツンとちょっと
下がったけど2年前に戻っちゃった感じで中性脂肪もあれ中人衆方がちょっといい感じ
か
うんそれで乗馬まあ
まあまあという感じですねはいここなんですがここがちょっと今回の問題って言うん
だったかなってとこですねコレステロールが上がってしまいましたら去年の結果
めちゃくちゃ良かったんですけどもこれなぜかというとはラー名を禁止していったから
なんですよねラーメン禁止がマジで体に良かったみたいです今年になってラーメン復帰
し今は食べてないんですけども
結局お肉とか食べちゃうと
やっぱ上がっちゃうみたいでまたお菓子とかないろんな原因があると思うんですけども
総合的に見るとランディを禁止していた頃よりもやっぱコレステロール値がた際で胸
近づいたということが明らかになりましたお医者さんっていたんですけどもラーメンは
とても危険な食べ物らしいでもうご褒美にたまに1回くらいならいいんですけどもそれ
は毎日の食べていると間違いなくストってしまうこれぞ私始め首都ラーメンを食べる
ペース
ちょっと見直そうかなと思っております現在ラーメン起きずしているんですけどまた
夏休み分けたこと要食べると思うんですけどもそんなに食べ過ぎずにまあご褒美程度に
ために食べるくらいでいいかなどを張っております以降ラーメタルの香津興が思います
後優しくれ食べます2で東大者も問題なかったですけど思いますあと肝機能とか何か
色々あるんですけども血液も問題なかったです
白血球血小板何も問題なかったです新年度も問題なし今日が問題なしばルームんでも
問題なし肺機能も問題なしというわけであのこれを今度覚えたんですけど
ラーメン屋灰になって思いますラーメン食べてない時と食べた時にこんなに修正しごと
に差が出るのかっていうねマーレンが全てと言わないですねも大きな原因はそこなのか
な
と思いました見て立って中性脂肪とコレステロールつ去年が良すぎてビビるもマジで2
年前と今年がもうあ高いんですけど去年がすげー結果が良くてやなんかね改めて墨運堂
ちゃんとしてるんであとは食生活とかお菓子とかかな
あと野菜をしっかり食べなきゃなって思いましたまあ南西なんかヤバい病気とか
見つからなくて本
文によかったです結構めちゃくちゃな生活してるんだよねなんだねほんとこいつよどっ
かで引っ掛かったりやばい何かをと爆弾抱えですので心配だったんですけども
毎年ちゃんとかって検査することによって早期発見もできるし今何かヤバイことがあっ
たら早めに号決心がつくというか何にせよあの早期発見が一番大事なので人間ドック
受けててよかったなと思います
大変だ
だけど粘り運動部のとかマジできついからねいつ付でと毎年ですね最後に障害ボック表
犯されるんですよ
生涯の目標をどうしますかというのは今年の傷害保険はこちらです
海津校に俺はなる
[音楽]
me
バッハ